Let's now look at how Teams may work with Take Recorder.
So as we mentioned in the opening slides,
you'll capture this Take Recorder content
and use it via Sequencer.
Now, Sequencer has some great sub scene tools to use.
So we can see that there's various tracks
as a sub scene within the master sequence.
So we can hold a sequence with all our shot information
at the top there.
And then also the sub scene tracks,
you can almost think about them as layers
and maybe a DCC app.
You can see that different departments can then work
and organize depending on what is actually happening
in the scene.
So you can see that we split the sub scenes
into character animation, effects, cameras, lighting, sound.
But again, that's going to be dependent
on the size of your project and what departments you have.
And then we can also say within this animation track,
for example, we have multiple animators
or multiple character performances
that we want to keep isolated.
So you can see that we have a meerkat, an eagle
and an egg sub scene as well.
So you can nest them within each sub scene as well.
So you can get as granular as you want here.
You don't want to get overly complex unnecessarily
and be unable to find the information,
but needless to say, using sub scene tracks
can help you quickly organize
and break down workflows between departments there.
It's also worth noting that you can record microphone inputs
into the tape recorder and therefore be able to edit
the audio within Sequencer.
So using audio gain multiplies the incoming audio power.
So gain can make it a blow out if the gain is too high
and the audio is too low, loud, sorry.
But the most important feature is the ability
to split stereo channels into separate tracks
for later editing.
So it's good for two person conversations.
You can also include more than one input.
So if you need to record any kind of audio information
whilst doing your takes, then that is also an option
through the source inside the tape recorder.